all of them of course you have to be
fair you got to say
some I was thinking about that this week
yeah yeah I'm about certain things yeah
I need to correct myself some people
yeah because not all people so in a
situation not
all Muslims are x-y not all Christian
are not all Jews are that so we got to
have a distinction I'm put this right
content thank you you're right yeah man
that's something I got this we ald we
know we know that a long time ago Allah
mentioned that the Quran Allah know
Allah that need to be spread but also
also even if you have problem with the
people okay
problem Su go with the coffee or the tea
um I think I proba find it yeah why we
saying Islam teaches us even if you have
problem with the people do not let them
and do not stand them be just even in
your hatred be just Your Love be just in
your be just that's what is
US yeah how come you didn't know about
should generalize everyone huh how come
you know about sometime we got to be
reminded that's good alhamdulillah you
believe in God oh God I don't like to
use the word
believe know Creator we say we
believe I would put it this way if there
wasn't a quan or Bible or any religious
writing yes doubtlessly Beyond Reason
never doubt Beyond religious Educators
or philosophers or what you call
them I know that I know that I
know not there is a God God
is so so so if you know there's
many uh should I say attributes or many
manifestations of who God really is
because we all take things at different
intervals like grade one grade two
different grades so God will speak to
you at the level of our knowledge and
understanding that we are at for example
no what I'm saying to you look put put
scripture aside that's why I was asking
I was asking you I'm asking you based
upon scripture I'm asking you I'm asking
you from rological natural ination point
of view well and you said you said there
is no doubt there is God you know got to
be of course all person say is God they
got to be foolish I like the answer I
like that thank you very much so the
point that's why when a
person um neglect the existence of the
true and living God yeah sometime you
can listen to them but don't take on
everything on board yes but if because
even the devil know and if the devil
know or Angel know that there is a God
much more man and woman who are made in
the likeness and the image of God Even
Adam and Eve know that there so you
believe in scripture then if I believe I
believe in the author of the scripture
the Old Testament yeah because have
authority over the scripture the script
is just the Au
expression no I said the
Au I believe in the author the
scriptures are just
expression yeah that's what I'm saying
which author so you canot have a
scripture without the author so the
author is irrelevant the the scriptures
are irrelevant without knowing the
author you have to know the arthor have
a revelation of who the author is okay
so now because the author know the ends
from the beginning
is before the beginning and before the
end which scripture you believe in the
scriptures of the Holy prophets when I
say scripture the revelation of truth
that comes from the revelation of light
brings knowledge wisdom understanding
which one which one there are many you
cannot choose one because if you choose
one and you ignore the others you are
doubting the veracity of the originality
you believe all of you believe in all of
them I believe in the Holy true rightous
Prophet even
Prophet simple English everyone that
bring the truth of the Living God but
how do you know they bring the truth if
I say if I say I believe in one I will
make myself a lie you know why because
all the prophets must say the true thing
you right yes of all the other prophets
going back before time you're right% I
agree with that they deviate from that
they're teaching another Doctrine or
another word that is
what you saying he go God never told me
to believe in the Bible he never tell me
to believe he told he told you told
Allah Allah
said in the Quran there is no part in
the SC you me keep cutting me I'm not
cutting you I'm
just my first I don't want to keep take
care of yourself let me look for someone
sincere how are you sir you all right
what's your name huh Ethan it's not good
for you Ethan SM okay what's your name
my name is CH where you from London
London west or east east London yes I
used to live in East
stford are you a Christian or aist
you're a Catholic so you believe in
Jesus to be
God you know as a human being God gave
us sound intellect yes and some of us
more than others yeah yeah yeah but but
I'm talking about that call com sense
which everyone share it yeah like if you
ask any human being you said do you
accept god is perfect and imperfect at
the same time that doesn't make any
sense because if we do establish god is
perfect then he if it's not perfect all
the time it's could stay imperfect at
any time do you agree with
that I think you would agree with me
when I would say I wouldn't say what God
can and can't do no are you putting
limitations on God
perfect I mean
sure that God can't do God not be two
things at the same time no there's
difference between what God does and
what God is you you are mixing and
overing I just walk the spirit of the
lead me to man a real man so so so
you're mixing between what God eat and
what God
does tell me what God is
is I good God is ever living you agree
yeah he has no beginning end yeah is it
is it logical to say God is ever living
but at the same time God is dead God
experienced death what do you mean
experienced death me he died experience
death so experience death what do you
mean by that he didn't die yeah didn't
die is in SE existing but experien what
it feels like to guys he knows
way yeah but he experienced in death is
deficiency yeah yeah God felt death but
God is not deficieny God felt death God
can't feel death God can't experience
death you putting limitations God again
that's very strange no you're putting
limit limitation to God you know why
experien if God experienced death is not
powerful to overpower death okay came
back from the dead he overow no but but
it did affect him he experienced death
affecting so God felt so God was
affected by death yeah felt that so God
was affected by death yeah experienced
that was affect show me when the Bible
says
that show me when the Bible says God
experienced that Jesus died on the cross
no no I'm not tell you what you believe
about Jesus said God show in the Bible
it says that God Bible says that Jesus
is God in the Epistles of Paul it says
Jesus Is God and then in the Gospels it
says Jesus died on the cross there you
go so so the Bible said Jesus Is God
clearly yeah says not in the gospel
where you read the Epistles have you
read the Epistles before I have read the
Epistles so Jesus said clearly I am God
no the Bible says that Jesus is God
Jesus wasn't clear about the gospels do
you know the difference between the
Gospels and the Epistles of course I
know that very well fantastic so you're
being dishonest said where in the Bible
does it say that have you seen you know
the Epistles of Paul do you know
so so Jesus he was too embarrassed to
call himself God I don't know why he
didn't do it I how come God was more
Brave to call himself God in the Old
Testament so therefore the god that you
believe in he's not true putting
imitations on God
again God can't do theun God be a man no
God took on a human nature the says he
became he says no no you you can phras
it however you want God took on a human
nature God took on a human nature okay
human nature is it human nature is
limited or
unlimited let me let me let me let me I
know I know let mear let me let me Lear
you said we liit God I'm going to show
you he just told me God took human
nature so God was limited by human
nature which is
limited yeah you believe Jesus you
coming too close Okay so no no no you
have to come too close to listen to you
except if you believe you're my wife I
you not my wife the only one that can do
that is my wife my wife can come close
to me to make me make you know okay
anyway go of Jesus Christ yes I know he
was a God and a human at the same time
that's what you believe I'm wrong two
Natures one person yes two nature and
one person divine nature human nature
okay so he was which part of Jesus was
divine the divine nature I don't know
see Christianity doesn't make any sense
that's why Church is
that's why church are
to he just told me so you have a
knowledge that Jesus was God and him the
same time but when I ask you which part
of Jesus was divine you went like
a your does know can you tell me your no
no inside me that's it it's inside me my
heart inside me I can show you my heart
anyway so it was inside him so you just
limited God by seeing God who inside him
limited again so he Limited limited
himself but you
just you just I'm limited God you
limited God God limited himself are you
listening to yourself or no you just
told me I'm limiting God when I ask you
you limited God and you admit you limit
God okay have you have you been church
today yeah that's why it makes sense now
that's why talking nonsense that's the
outcome of going church when start
talking nonsense you know that's why
Christians out there leave church this
real living example when you go Church
you start contradicting your own brain
you are a victim of your own brain and
is the outcome of it according to Islam
worship God Al who that
God look look look a beautiful
description of Allah say Allah is one
unique he be not neither was he begotten
and there's nothing like onto
him him they don't they don't want
people to hear the truth they keep
interrupting let me see the truth I you
all
right have a good conversation all right
anyway let me let me carry on so when
you look to Allah Allah describe
himself Allah himself the most
beneficent the most
merciful the most loving Allah would do
for his servant just to gain his
servant's love even though Allah is a
need of his servant's love but when you
look at Christianity God become a baby
but baby is not God but God with a baby
then someone had to breastfeed him but
God doesn't get breastfeed but God is is
sufficient but someone had take care of
him that doesn't make any sense come to
Islam come to the teaching of Jesus come
the teach of Muhammad Moses leave the
teaching of the Pagan Romans leave the
teach the teaching of Paul Paul's
teaching corrupted the true teaching of
Jesus you know the teaching of Jesus
there's only one God perfect God the
teaching of all God human everything
anyway what we say to you long time ago
if you didn't notice I'm just preaching
now yeah I know I know it's nonsense but
you're very okay let ask if it's No
Nonsense is God one yes so how you say
nonsense I said
a Muslim say nonsense even he agrees
with it he agrees that God is one okay
okay is does does anyone give birth to
God yes the father no Mary so go you see
you see that see the father beli in we
say the true God but they ask another
God is the father fully God yes he's
fully God the father is identical to the
Divine listen carefully is the father
fully God my question so if the father
fully God how many God we have
one have one one is J fully God how many
God you have so far you need to go to
hospital yes anyway someone else
seriously yeah run away from you is a
virtue to be honest I'm going to give to
someone can I fly fully yes you want to
speak to me can you show me your
certificate from the
hospital I need hosital you're the one
with the cane you saw me your
certificate with from the hospital yeah
k
what like youe him you agree with him
listen should I heal you cuz it seem
like you you agree with
him to don't worry anyway my dear
brothers and sisters let us talk about
Ramadan the importance of Ramadan and we
have two weeks left or less more than
two weeks Ramadan will come in Allah
they jealous of quan why we are able to
recite Arabic language they English
Jesus English Arabic anyway Arabic
Ramadan a month which the Quran was
revealed that's
why Arabic anyway Arab you scar
conversation why you scar ofers you just
told two goods one why are you scared
ofers have you same brain like you
I I AMR yes
mhamad anyway so Ramadan theth of
Ramadan we have to prepare our our we
have to prepare ourselves mentally
psychologically you one of them is okay
and spiritually to meet Ramadan because
Ramadan is not about don't fast no also
about trying our best to stay away from
that which
Allah Allah when he the father okay I'm
going to move away because he just next
to my